[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de tv
fil 78 voici les titres en images de ce
23 février à 2017
ça y est c'est officiel c'est fait
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a vendu ce matin son réseau
câblé à l'opérateur sfr une signature à
15 millions d'euros à laquelle s'ajoute
une modernisation du réseau
quels changements pour les utilisateurs
politique et le fn toujours en campagne
malgré les accusations d' emplois
fictifs au parlement européen le chargé
de campagne de marine le pen était hier
à versailles
y at il un pilote dans l'avion c'est en
substance la question de la cour des
comptes sur le projet paris saclay le
point sur la situation et les réactions
des principaux concernés
à suivre au cours de ce journal à partir
d'aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 3 mars se
déroule à saint quentin en yvelines la
semaine de l'emploi différents
événements sont organisés pour
s'informer s'orienter découvrir les
métiers qui recrutent rencontrer les
entreprises également ce jeudi
l'association rencontres pour l'égalité
d'accès à l'emploi organise avec saint
quentin en yvelines et mord pas un coup
de pouce pour l'emploi vous envoyer les
images et puis demain vendredi a noté un
forum des formations aux métiers ouverts
au grand public uniquement entre 17 et
20 heures ce sera au pavillon
waldeck-rousseau sur la commune de lui
en cours cette fois ci emploie toujours
et le lancement aujourd'hui de la job
academy au prêt est de la sodexo le
principe est simple des salariés de
l'entreprise de services dont le siège
est basé à montigny le bretonneux vont
accompagner des demandeurs d'emploi
durant les prochaines semaines le
dispositif existait déjà auprès d'autres
sociétés sur saint quentin en yvelines
également est ce le dispositif dans
l'entreprise sodexo a été lancé
aujourd'hui le reportage de michael et
demi d'euros et de mélanie poquet
depuis aujourd'hui ils sont liés pour
quatre mois 19 fillol demandeurs
d'emploi et 19 par un employé de la
sodexo se sont rencontrés pour la
première fois il participe à une
nouvelle session de la job academy de
face qui disons que c'est vraiment un
accompagnement de rendez vous tous les
quinze jours pour vraiment créer une
dynamique
on n'est pas dans l'emploi donc c'est
clair aussi c'est important que les
bénéficiaires comprennent ça c'est que
sodexo ya on va pas les embaucher voilà
le but c'est d'avoir un regard extérieur
d'une personne qui va l'accompagner qui
valent à dynamiser elle trouvera toute
seule et elle trouve toute seule
c'est le cas de sylvie elle est en
recherche d'emploi depuis fin novembre
et souhaite rester sur saint quentin en
yvelines
en fait ça fait plusieurs années que
j'enchaîne les cdd et l'intérim
ça m'a convenu pendant un certain temps
j'ai appris plein de choses en
différents secteurs d'activité mais
maintenant j'aimerais me poser pour
aller vraiment vers un poste qui va me
convenir un secteur qui va me convenir
moi je trouve que c'est important pour
les gens qui sont en poste dans une
entreprise comme la nôtre
dd quand je dis aider c'est donner des
clés de réussite pour que les gens qui
sont difficulté ou en recherche d'emploi
on leur donne les bonnes clés de
compréhension du monde de l'entreprise
telle qu'on la vit aujourd'hui de
l'intérieur comme sylvie les filles
elles rencontreront leurs parrains et
marraines tous les quinze jours
plus de 60% des bénéficiaires ont
recommencé une activité
six mois après la fin de leur job
academy économie après deux ans de
discussions de pourparlers c'est donc
officiel ce matin l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines s'est séparé
de son art réseaux câblés auprès de
l'opérateur sfr la signature elle
fascine tout de même les 15 millions
d'euros et pour les utilisateurs c'est
surtout une bonne nouvelle puisque
l'opérateur annonce l'arrivée du très
haut débit pour tous
mélanie poker c'est une nouvelle étape
pour le câble à saint quentin en
yvelines l agglomération a signé ce
matin la vente de son réseau à
l'opérateur sfr
une session à 15 millions d'euros la
guinée d'agglomération j'ai fait le
choix en 2007 de devenir propriétaire
du réseau qui était exploitée par
numericable entre-temps numericable a
été racheté par sfr et donc nous avons
souhaité nous en 2014
tout simplement nous recentrer sur les
activités d'une collectivité et le côté
très technique de l'exploitation d'un
réseau câblé nous avons souhaité
aujourd'hui nous ont séparés 50 % de
cette somme ira directement dans les
caisses de l'agglomération et les autres
50 pensons seront directement investis
sur les réseaux aux bénéfices et bien
sûr des saint quentinois
l'accord conclu prévoit aussi la
modernisation du réseau d'ici la fin de
l'année 2017 soixante mille logements
supplémentaires de l'agglomération
auront accès au très haut débit à un
gigabit par seconde
comment ça se passe techniquement
parlant aujourd'hui on va déployer de la
fibre c'est à dire qu'on va remplacer le
câble existantes dans la rue par de la
fibre optique qu'on va amener au pied
des bâtiments
en revanche on va garder
l'infrastructure existante dans l'est
notamment dans les immeubles pour éviter
pour démonter pour éviter de déployer de
la fibre en local
dirt percer les murs chez les ch et
délais dans les logements des habitants
cette commune de l'agglomération seront
concernés les travaux ont débuté sur
montigny le bretonneux dans cette
commune 1720 logements et locaux
professionnels sont dès aujourd'hui
éligibles au très haut débit une silicon
valley à la française c'est l'ambition
du projet paris est saclay qui
regroupera à terme une université
internationale des centres de recherche
ou encore à des entreprises innovantes
seulement la cour des comptes vient de
pointer plusieurs faiblesses dans son
rapport annuel a notamment sur
l'aménagement du territoire sur
l'organisation de cette université
commune bonsoir nicolas beau soir
wilfried quels sont justement les
principales critiques aujourd'hui de la
cour des comptes alors wilfried il faut
tout d'abord savoir que c'est
l'établissement public d'aménagement de
paris saclay qui a en charge la
construction de ce territoire est l'une
de ses principales missions c'est
l'accueil de près de 54 mille étudiants
et le problème c'est que la cour prévoit
un déficit de plus de 2000 logements sur
le campus dès 2018
l'autre difficulté c'est le manque de
moyens de transport à court terme
trois projets sont en cours sur la zone
de paris saclay et il ya aussi la ligne
18 du métro prévue elle pour l'année
2024 sur ce sujet écouter michel bournat
il est président de la communauté paris
saclay il suffit de voir les grues sur
le territoire avec la réalisation ou des
projets de construction pour accueillir
les établissements d'enseignement pour
accueillir les étudiants pour accueillir
les futurs habitants pour accueillir les
entreprises
ce qui compte c'est que tous les
partenaires un moment donné partage des
enjeux les la vision de l'aménagement
dans toutes ses composantes
c'est comme ça qu'on avance alors qu'est
un coordinateur en chef parmi les autres
que l'ordinateur
dont acte mais c'est pas forcément enjeu
déterminant je crois que la coopération
en quel lieu au cours des derniers mois
entre tous les acteurs le démontre qu'on
avance
concernant l'université paris saclay à
présent elle englobe 18 établissements
la cour pointe ici des divergences sur
la mutualisation des moyens notamment un
conflit entre deux établissements
d'un côté l'université paris sud qui
souhaiteraient créer une université
unifiée en mettant en commun les
différents niveaux et la recherche de
l'autre
l'école polytechnique qui veut défendre
sa réputation et préconise une alliance
des grandes écoles d'ingénieurs du
plateau de saclay à ce propos écoutez le
président de l'université versailles
saint quentin didier guillemot nous
l'avions reçu notamment sur notre
plateau je pense que les choses avancent
effectivement pas si rapidement que sa
voix mais elle avance aussi avec
plusieurs partenaires à plus de 18
presque 20 je pense que le pilotage est
bien et plutôt pas si malmené que ça et
on va voir dans les mois qui viennent la
manière dont le jury international david
ex en l'occurrence et bien reçoit les
propositions qui seront faites
alors nicolas de ce projet paris saclay
est ce que la cour des comptes retient
tout de même des éléments positifs
alors malgré ses cris tricks et critique
wilfried la cour des comptes reconnaît
plusieurs réussites comme la délivrance
de diplômes sous le label université
paris saclay mais il faut savoir que ce
projet de paris saclay est en cours de
réalisation
c'est un projet à long terme et donc il
pourrait aboutir dans les dix voire
vingt prochaines années
on verra comment l'établissement
paris-saclay va essayer de redresser la
barre face à toutes ces critiques merci
nicolas politique et jenlain elle la
capelle qui était à versailles hier il
est en charge de la campagne pour la
présidentielle de
marine le pen il revient sur les
principaux axes du programme et puis
également sur la polémique des emplois
fictifs qui touche sa formation le
reportage est signée michael et demi
d'euros le front national se met en
ordre de marche dans les yvelines
à deux mois du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle est une
conférence pour présenter la stratégie
du parti est organisée ce mercredi 22
février à versailles
parmi les partisans jardin la capelle
membres du conseil stratégique de la
campagne du fn et conseiller régional
d'île de france
nous avons tout simplement mis en place
une équipe tournée marine 2007 nous
avons décidé en six semaines de visiter
les 95 fédérations française et dans les
îles ils auront leur contribution aussi
et nous sommes là pour convaincre les
quelques hésitant encore où les quelques
électeurs volatile objectif annoncé par
le front national dans les yvelines 21%
premier tour de la présidentielle un
score largement envisageable selon les
partisans à chaque élection on a
progressé on est parti de lui de 1 8%
régionales 2010 par exemple pour arriver
à 20% 19 ans 120% au départemental et
aux régionales
donc on peut espérer à la présidentielle
ça se déroule de la même façon au même
moment l'enquêté sur les emplois fictifs
présumés au parlement européen a pris
une nouvelle tournure avec la mise en
examen de catherine grise et proche
collaboratrice de marine le pen à faire
cesser l'opération politique les gens
font la différence entre les affaires
qui ont dû contenu les affaires qui
n'ont pas de contenu qui sort du
registre de l'opération politique
donc je leur fais totalement confiance
est d'ailleurs en voie de sondage il ya
aucun à ce rythme en ce qui veut bien
dire que c'est lisse et ksar cool une
affaire qui ne devrait pas perturber
l'organisation du grand meeting parisien
le 17 avril prochain le seul rendez-vous
en ile de france la fédération des îles
unis participera en l'envoyant une
délégation l'actualité locale c'est
aussi à la verrière la l'officialisation
avec une signature d'un jumelage avec la
ville de khobar en cisjordanie une
délégation palestine était
à l'estonienne pardon m'est arrivé cette
semaine elle a rencontré les habitants
après une visite de la ville ce matin
ils ont échangé avec associations et
riverains cette coopération avec khobar
est porté par l'association pour une
paix juste israélo-palestiniennes
écouter les impressions de la délégation
palestinienne c'est au micro de camille
lambert et des gladiateurs à fouras
c'est un plaisir pour nous
personnellement et pour notre ville
d'avoir ce type de relation avec la
verrière ans et bénéteau of la berrière
c'est une très jolie ville et nous
espérons qu'avec cette coopération est
la verrière coparent se développent de
la même manière en palestine et 20
octobre est assez meulage c'était une
palestine la culture à présent vivre
ensemble respecter l'autre avec ses
différences c'est dans cet esprit qu'une
vingtaine d'artistes retourne à l'école
c'est dans le cadre de la 6e édition de
l'opération un artiste à l'école qui va
se terminer le 21 avril 2017 et cette
semaine rencontre avec le documentariste
jean robert il s'est rendu au lycée
jules ferry à versailles cela faisait
trente ans que le documentariste jean
robert viallet n'avait pas remis un pied
au lycée jules ferry à versailles mais
cette fois ils ne seront pas pour rendre
des devoirs ou prendre des cours non
cette fois il est de retour pour
transmettre son expérience au lycée ce
que je vais essayer de leur dire moi
c'est que le lycée ça définit plein de
choses mais ça définit pas tout le
parcours de vie s'est il est riche il
est
plein d'embûches cad de chaos de
reconstruction nos changements opérés
que voilà moi ce que j'ai envie de leur
dire c'est ça c'est que la vie est
devant eux et que tous construits à
force d'obstination surtout le
dispositif
un artiste à l'école est à la fois
pédagogique et artistique
parrainé par le ministère de l'éducation
la marraine cette année c'est la
réalisatrice catherine corsini connu
pour ses films comme la nouvelle eve ou
la belle saison pour elle l'initiative
est importante
ils sont généralement très enthousiastes
ils sont ravis d'entendre quelqu'un qui
n'est pas un prof quelqu'un qui n'est
pas un parent quelqu'un qui est notre
par rapport à leur vie mais qui à ce
point commun avec eux d'être lancé donc
ça crée un lien il se paraient des
questions qu'ils n'oseraient pas c'était
une conférence classique ou telle
personnalité vient par l'équipemetier un
artiste à l'école continue son chemin
jusqu'au 27 avril
ils reviendront le 30 mars à l'école
condamine à versailles avec l'artiste
plasticien jean faucheur et pour
terminer ce journal les images du
festival féminin pluriel qui se poursuit
dans le département des yvelines nous en
parlons régulièrement sur cette antenne
aujourd'hui la compagnie pièce montée
proposer son spectacle regarde les
lumières mon amour d'après le journal as
d'annie ernaux au théâtre eurydice à
plaisir une pièce qui dénonce la place
de la femme dans la société de
consommation féminin pluriel le festival
lui se poursuit au cours des prochaines
semaines nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir c'est la fin de ce journal
demain l'hebdo avec nikola kirilow vide
c'est son invité pour l'actu du jour
l'essentiel de la semaine également en
attendant les programmes se poursuivre
sur notre antenne très belle soirée
[Musique]